hello everyone i'm kimberly guilfoyle
along with Geraldo Rivera Pete hexa Dana
Perino and Greg duck phone it's five
o'clock in New York City and this is the
five
[Music]
it's Memorial Day the unofficial start
to summer so grab your margaritas and
your hot dog and let's have some fun
because it's time for the Memorial Day
fan mail special we're gonna answer your
questions throughout the hour so shall
we begin
alrighty so we're gonna start out right
away with the Instagram questions are
you guys ready uh-huh
yes all right Lee instantly for
Instagram immediamente all right this is
from ped snur see something is there you
go I mean my best with that and so this
is really a basic like Memorial Day
question do you go Hot Diggity Dog or do
you go Hamburglar are you asking me
again first of all I want to point out
that you should grab your margaritas I
think it's horrible that we're starting
off with cultural appropriation we
should be drinking Pabst Blue Ribbon hot
like the Rideau identity politics is
killing all of us hot dogs or hamburgers
I'm more of a hot burger which is eating
a hamburger with my shirt off wow that's
really because it's covering up
Geraldo doing that is one thing I'm
curious about this hot dog or hamburger
and how does the vote go in your hat is
it on Memorial Day or in general um I
would say Memorial Day I'd go on the
hotdog okay I don't have hot dogs
regularly but I would have a hamburger
regularly okay
hot dogs like a special occasion does
the term dog in it upsets you that I was
the relation to Jess not at all I'm very
comfortable with the hot dog what about
Peter yeah I don't know what pudding
he likes blood pudding yeah laughing
yeah hilarious
I know you're probably gonna want both
knowing yours right yeah but I quote the
great pandering sage Mitt Romney my
favorite meat is hot dog my second
favorite meat is hamburger not steak
because I'm one of the command of the
people well of course it's both and hot
dog first then as much of a hamburger as
you can get and then probably back to a
hot dog yeah and it's a running thing
throughout the day as the grill goes
that's the thing and then you have to
see like if the hot dogs look endangered
like too many people are grabbing them
you got to get that one first then you
move to the burner no bun well that's
the problem
if you don't have an even matchup of
buns and dogs you're in big trouble and
that's led to actual death that yes can
you actually have the hot burner yeah I
cut it the hot dog in half you got put
on a burger exactly that's been done as
well okay so we had an elevator first
car when you have your Memorial Day
soiree
yes ma'am I don't know if it's on your
boat do you do you grill on your hot dog
hamburger i I go for Nathan's kosher hot
dogs and those it makes him and they
they cook very crispy on the outside so
when you bite in it's kind of like a
it's like a zing zing sear somebody's
eye out
I would say I love hamburgers but I also
have hot dogs I probably eat at least
two hot dogs every week but I have those
that like kosher national Hebrew
National was it was quite tasty and I
think that story you lost an hour of
life for every hotdog you Twitter
question Greg you love Twitter in
playground okay this is from at Wendy
lady NJ
all right favorite barbecue food I know
you like barbecue I love barbecue so
much my favorite barbecue food has to be
the rutabaga a lot of people don't
barbecue rutabagas they eat them raw
yeah but a good barbecued rutabaga can't
go wrong with it through the ribs and
the steaks and the burgers go with a
rutabaga this year America you won't be
sorry okay and eat it in the Winnebago
okay no comment but they have paid me
handsome a to play yes that a [ __ ] to
disclose yes it is miss Moreno now what
is that what is your favorite barbecue
food well I guess coleslaw at the
barbecue is true not she's guests but
you know barbecue it Dan you barbecue
corn yeah there you go that's a good one
that is a good one you can also
microwave it with a wet towel for a
couple of minutes quite tasty two
minutes per night I don't know you knew
that that's a good little team you
taught me that okay somebody's gonna
have to explain to me how we got I'm the
third person to answer about barbecue
and we haven't talked about
well I'm gonna say ribs and cold pork
especially if they're done really well
and I'm not good at it I don't do a lot
of home barbecuing I'm a pretty simple
burgers and dogs it steaks it's
phenomenal even when I were to Chinese
food I go with the spareribs and like I
think they're fantastic barbecue spare
me have more dangerously then I'm very a
very dangerous yeah I was dangerous for
the pig
definitely ribs well well cook crispy
crispy burnt and end corn on the cob
okay so everybody loves that butter no
butter I don't know take it out of the
butter can't believe it's not butter
Fabio Fabio
what's a barbecue without Fabio oh I
wouldn't call it a barbecue at all not
enough no Bobby Oh meat there yeah I did
answer because I copied Pete and did the
pulled pork same situation with the ribs
yums all right no no please set me up
with him though yes I did I tried to set
her up with Fabio but she was involved
with somebody else what's his name
belief it was Yanni what is your
favorite tradition to kick off summer
that's I'm Sara that's probably when we
you know we get things out of storage
like aunt Helen I live in an apartment
in New York the only thing you do is you
turn on the air conditioning and hope it
works yeah that's all that's my
tradition you know things look a
favorable Dana I think well if that's
not really kicking it off but I always
think of the summer when the dogs are no
longer allowed on the beach Labor Day
the dogs aren't allowed so you got to
give them their one last big freedom
session all right since I'll go serious
for a second since Memorial Day is the
kickoff for summer its memorializing
this a day which we talk about barbecues
and we should have fun but the first
thing you need to do is remember all
those men and women that gave everything
AB so that we can sit at this table
today and I know everyone here knows
that but you have to remind yourself and
if you got kids sit them down and tell
them why this day matters why we have
this day off why we're barbecuing and
take them to the parade or take them to
the ceremony in your town it's actually
very powerful so
for that it's the guys who gave
everything not to not today there's
Veterans Day today is Memorial Day it's
for the ones that are still quite good
point and July 4th has a great parade
yes in every small town every small town
I've ever liked having all the kids who
are at least in the country come to fall
this day I like ok fans have my summer
that's a lot of kids for and now with
the grandkid that's a little crowd and
burgeoning crafts spot oh my favorite
tradition to kick off summer would
obviously be the hot tub no question
about it I love it it just feels like
it's summer then it's happy it does to
me yes because when you get out you're
still warm
yeah guys and then you can have little
snacks in the hot tub you should be
careful and talk to your doctor about it
before you do snacks liquid snack well
it's name Packers that's the same thing
you know hot tub in the Hamptons I don't
know this is a table of the people all
right with Bobby oh yeah yeah 100% as
long as he puts his hair back in a
ponytail
it's a gram question from Al well who
knows it's a LTZ our trough something of
that nature what is your favorite
vacation location and do you prefer
summer Dana or winter vacation Oh summer
vacations and where do I go I like to go
anywhere but I'm I have come to have a
lot of affection for the Jersey Shore
Yeah right in bay head and I also what's
the address South Carolina and also I do
feel like it's summer when I head back
west of Wyoming or Colorado that always
feels like summer to me I spent my youth
there okay I like that's very good and
the pictures are beautiful check out our
Instagram all right what about you Greg
think I I think you know the answer I my
favorite place is home I go nowhere
I don't leave I like theirs to me I can
create an entire vacation in my head and
without having to get on a plane I hate
traveling so I that's my buy vacation
plus we vacations everyone else suffers
cuz you would think you would come back
chipper happy with
sunny disposition but he comes like
cranky he talks about the coco loom I
always come back with some kind of
illness the last time I went to was in
Mexico I had a bull's-eye bruised UNITA
take four weeks of antibiotics for that
ringworm or something yeah yeah I got
ringworm from camp I'll never forget
that and but no every time I come back
something is wrong with ya different by
the world is the world is dangerous GI
disorder inside being inside is the best
place we evolved as as human beings to
create our own dwellings we don't have
to go outside anymore
you're a cave dweller I am because every
day could be a vacation for you yes
right now you don't even know and a
glass of Pinot your book very good so I
like read game I like summer vacations
in winter going to places where it is
warm during the winter time like Mexico
I like Mexico last time I was in Mexico
I got a tattoo so you go there to get a
tattoo
no it wasn't yeah yes I've been
traveling all my life you know the half
century been on the in the television
news business and I've seen basically
the whole globe but Eric is so much
younger and and now it's old 12 years
old
so we're redoing all of the places that
I'd like Paris this June sure next month
and she loves that and visit all of the
tourist spots and I dragged my sorry
behind dinner again
are you gonna take her time at rush man
so no I don't know if I'll take her
there
yeah that's really a motor that's a
motorcycle one thing Epcot Center and
then you have to go anywhere else you're
indoors he just became the travel agency
I've got Center they have all the food
around the world you never have to leave
okay all right so my favorite vacation
look I would have
to say it's Mexico I'm no longer allowed
there many engagements so I'm gonna have
to find a new one so that's why I don't
do walls okay so we've got time for one
more please do a speed round on this
bridge so put the pedal to the metal on
this what is your favorite pastime when
you have some time off and this is from
[Laughter]
skip me home home or at the bar local
bar wine mm-hmm writing a book there you
go that's all you that's what I do
followed by complaining followed by
embarrassing drunken tweets that I have
to answer for the next day why yes with
just why why not please don't do this
anymore
sincerely executives the new band called
executive all right Dana what is your
favorite pastime I came out with family
and friends my husband Peter and our dog
Jasper but I also really love to read
fiction you love so if I get extra a
little bit at time to myself I try to do
that you like to go to the beach too
with Jasper that's a do or and until
he's kissed you read the New York Times
okay sweet Pete well I mean throwing the
football around with the kids on the
beach whatever or the pool food drinks
nothing you know son shut it down
maybe read a book good they're quite
good okay I love being on the water as
you know just took my boat from New York
Harbor or up the Hudson River Erie Canal
Lake Erie to Cleveland so I went to
Cleveland after my boat and I loved
being on the boat
alright so favorite pastime I like to
read that's for sure and then also I
like to go to the park the park is very
fun which parking what time the park in
[Laughter]